[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to AMC's The Walking Dead has just
dropped its final episode for season 9
and throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the episode this is full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen it
and don't want to know what happens and
I highly suggest that you turn off now
as this has a lot of big moments in it
that definitely deserved to be seen with
fresh eyes that's your last warning and
without the way let's dive into the
season 9 finale of The Walking Dead
episode 16 titled the storm fittingly
picks up after the events of episode 15
the calm before do you see what they did
there anyway in that episode alpha
pretty much showcased herself as well
the Alpha as not only did she decapitate
10 of the show's c-listers she also
showed Daryl a massive hoard of walkers
that she threatened to unleash on the
communities if they were ever to step
foot in whisper territory again at least
she gotta wear a nice hat though anyway
episode 16 thrust the titular storm our
characters and these guys do not deal
well with it
alpha hinted that the future would be
sweater weather but I thought she was
just talking about something to go along
with her very nice little hat anyway
it's pretty clear that the circumstances
are causing everyone to be down about
the entire staying alive thing with
Lydia even contemplating death by zombie
by but more on that later
Ezekiel and Daryl have a big argument
and Zeke straight-up tells him that life
would be better at Hilltop without him
and all-in-all it's clear that
everything has affected everyone very
badly the storm isn't bad for everyone
though with negan get moved from his
cell and actually getting a chance to
redeem himself when he runs into the
snow after Judith to rescue her and just
like that we forgot about him smashing
Glenn's head into smithereens and
embraced him as an upstanding member of
the
Michelle even visits the character in
the same room where he recovered from
Rick's throat slice and you can begin to
see them at least warming to each other
negan - gives her advice on perspective
and being a leader and even talks about
how when they're in charge no one thinks
they're the evil one which gives a nice
POV on some of the decisions that he
made what works so well about the snow
in this episode is that it makes all of
the journeys between the towns
life-or-death situations after a pit
stop at the sanctuary the Hilltoppers
are forced across throughout this
territory and whilst walkers appear the
true drama of this episode comes with
Lydia attempting suicide and begging
Carol to let her die Carol doesn't do it
though as she knows that Lydia is only
considering herself as weak because of
the abuse dealt to her by her mother
Carol might have seen most of the kid
she's looked after died in front of her
but she's not giving up and she embraces
Lydia which shows that she will always
try to care for the young as it's in
their nature eventually this causes
Carol to break the news that she's
heading for a town and in doing this it
confirms that the fantasy life she's
been living at the kingdom is no more I
guess some people just anchor out for
fairy tales
anyway the episode ends with two
cliffhangers while summer has started it
doesn't mean that things are gonna be
all sunshine the first cliffhanger comes
with a scene beta removing alphas mask
and she tells him that he needs to be
strong for what's to come next beta
starts whipping alpha across the wrist
and it becomes clear that this whole
anger is a driving force thing it's
really pushing her ahead obviously now
she knows that the group have entered
her territory at some point and is going
to do something about it I can see her
weaponizing the army of the undead that
she has at her disposal to take all of
the towns down in one fell swoop
cut to Zeke chatting to Judah through
his radio and it's a cute little moment
that shows just how strong the bonds
between the towns are Ezekiel walks off
probably a go look after his own child
oh wait and then a muffled voice comes
through the radio asking if anybody is
out there obviously the show is going to
need some new faces to kill off I mean
help with the whisper a war which is
just around the corner and whilst I
haven't seen anyone talking about who
this could be a personally thing that we
might see a return of Rick Grimes
through this a theorize that the voice
on the other end
could be the camp where he was rescued
and it would make sense for the three
standalone films that they are planning
to do with the character - firstly show
what's happened to him then secondly
show him reconnecting with the group and
thirdly show him helping how in the
whisperer wall who is this group exactly
while in the comic books they are known
as the Commonwealth and I introduced
when Eugene hears them over the radio
which is pretty similar to this in the
comics the person behind the voice is
known as Stephanie who lives in the
community which is by far the most
expansive and elaborate town in the
walking dead world it's a real
civilization with bakeries law firms
shops and more which further hammers
home just how medieval the kingdom is
it'll add a huge Game of Thrones style
aspect to the show as this becomes the
main story point once the whisperers are
done with it would make for a great
season going ahead and I really hope
it's the route that they go down
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on whether you agree with me or not so
make sure you leave them in the comments
below and let me know what you'd like to
see in season 10 which is due to air
later this year if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my breakdown of the
Annabelle comes home trailer which would
be linked at the end this is the channel
for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
you